on s'intéresse maintenant au festival
festival de musique
cet été tous n'ont pas renoncé à l'image
de terres du son qui se réinvente et
propose cinq jours de concerts au
domaine de candé amont ce sera du 9 au
14 juillet du côté des îlots
électronique à tour le festival
redémarre avec une nouvelle version une
grande parade dans les rues de la ville
le 27 juin les détails avec aurélie
renault dans les ateliers de la
compagnie off à saint-pierre-des-corps
les chars sont en préparation celui du
soleil et le tapis rouge façon croisette
des sharks et accompagneront la parade
des îlots électronique
cette année pas de lieu fixe pour les
concerts électro mais une déambulation
de trois heures avec les dj dans les
rues de la ville
le dernier dimanche de juin la parole ça
s'appelle boum boum boum
parce qu'on l'avait imaginé d'abord pour
fêter l'arrivée du printemps des beaux
jours et tout ça à début avril sur la
date d'origine
finalement ça sera plutôt une parade
summer of love début de l'été mais
l'idée c'est vraiment cette explosion
blum en anglais c'est l'éclosion à la
sortir de terre pour enfin reprendre le
soleil et refaire la fête tous ensemble
autre rendez vous musical terres du son
cette année la programmation est très
francophone sébastien tellier pomme ben
mazué gaël faye suzanne sera également
sur la scène le festival a accueilli
aussi l'auteur compositeur et interprète
hervé côté international c'est la soupe
jouera également au domaine de candé le
festival est rebaptisé midi-minuit
parterre du son aujourd'hui à l'heure où
on parle le festivalier et sera assis et
regardera les concerts face à deux
scènes qui joueront en alternance sûr
sûr sûr c'est que soirées et concerts
on entend par notamment la ministre de
la culture que le fil des festivals de
goût pourrait se dérouler à partir du
1er juillet tout en indiquant qu'il
faudrait quatre mètres carrés par
festivaliers alors qu'arte mètre carré
par festivaliers en l'état ça n'a aucun
sens sur nos activités
absolument pas imaginer mettre des croix
sur l'ensemble du site
par contre si éventuellement ces quatre
mètres carrés fois une jauge et qu'il
faut juste multiplier
7jours ça on peut on peut l'envisager
perdu son 2021 proposera bien des bars
et de la restauration
l'espace camping lui restera fermée